what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
if you thought marvel had revealed all
of their upcoming projects for the next
couple of years
well like me you were wrong marvel has
already announced their phase 4 slate
however during disney's investor day not
too long ago they announced a
ton of new projects coming to not only
theaters but disney plus as well
and this actually came as a shock to a
lot of people
a lot of people didn't know that marvel
had so many plans for so many more
series
and movies coming up in the near future
so it was a very pleasant surprise but
today
we have another pleasant surprise as it
has been revealed that marvel
actually has more in store for us than
they've currently revealed
they haven't revealed all of the
upcoming marvel phase 4 and phase 5
projects and this new report is coming
from somebody directly at
marvel now of course the big question is
what projects are they
hiding from us that they're going to be
revealing very soon
well in this video i'll break down some
projects that marvel could be revealing
pretty soon that are going to get you
excited about the future of the mcu
reminder my captain america shield
giveaway ends tomorrow so if you'd like
a chance to win be sure to check the
description for the
giveaway details now to start off as i
mentioned this report is actually coming
from
somebody at marvel a writer specifically
malcolm spellman
he of course was the writer of the
falcon and the winter soldier series and
as of recent reports is writing a fourth
captain america film and yesterday he
actually told us that there are more
marvel projects coming than we actually
knew about
in an interview with murphy's multiverse
he stated
i was surprised about how few of the
upcoming marvel movies have been
announced fans will start to become more
and more clear as these projects get
announced
so marvel has more projects in store for
us than they've mentioned so far
more than the marvel phase 4 slate that
they revealed at san diego comic con and
more than the upcoming projects they
announced at disney's investor day
so what could these projects be well i
have seven different projects that
marvel could be working on right now
that they could be revealing very soon
plus a bonus eighth project and let's
start with the first one which i believe
could be the midnight suns with the
announcement of blade coming to the mcu
and moon night it seems like the
midnight suns could be set up
relatively soon the midnight suns are a
little bit of a darker group of
superheroes
all with ties to the occult the group
was originally put together by doctor
strange to fight the fallen angel
lilith and her demon children again a
little darker group of superheroes but
that actually could be
fairly fitting for what the upcoming mcu
is going to look like
one division kind of took us a little
bit darker with the darkhold and witches
but of course blade is coming and
moon knight and doctor strange is
probably going to be fighting some
demons in multiverse of madness and
there will probably be more
after that which means it's a great time
to introduce the midnight suns
this would also open it up for
characters like ghostwriter and the
punisher to be on the team as well
the next secret project that marvel
could be working on right now
is a project that is reportedly already
in the works and that is the illuminati
this is a project that i am personally
very very excited for
in the comics the group consists of
doctor strange iron man
mr fantastic professor xavier black bolt
and neymar the submariner now obviously
the mcu is not going to have the exact
same characters after all iron man is
dead but the fantastic four are going to
be introduced to the mcu fairly soon
kevin feige has recently announced that
they are currently working on the film
so mr fantastic is definitely a
possibility
the mutants are also coming to the mcu
probably pretty soon as kevin feige
mentioned it a couple of years ago at
san diego comic con when he announced
marvel's phase 4 slate this means that
charles xavier is coming to the mcu
making him available for the illuminati
it's also been reported that namor is
supposed to come to the mcu soon as well
however it was reported that he was
going to be coming in black panther too
and of course since the sad passing of
chadwick boseman happened it's unclear
on whether or not
black panther 2 is going to go down that
direction however
of course they still could if they
wanted to and this could introduce
neymar and
atlantis and black panther 2 to the
marvel cinematic universe which means he
could be a part of the illuminati
now it's unclear on whether or not the
inhumans are going to be a part of the
mcu at some point in time
in a serious matter kamala khan is
supposed to be an inhuman
but right now it's kind of unclear on
what direction marvel's going to take
her so the possibility of
black belt appearing in the illuminati
is kind of slim now of course doctor
strange would be a part of it after all
he is kind of protecting the universe
and the reality as we know it and it
looks like he's going to be dealing a
lot with that in multiverse of madness
in fact i really wouldn't be surprised
if all the events that happen in
multiverse of madness are what makes him
start and form
the illuminati and although sadly iron
man is not going to be a part of the
illuminati in the mcu there are plenty
of other heroes that they could choose
from
some may even be introduced in these
projects that we're not aware of right
now
but the third project we kind of are
aware of and that is
the thunderbolts and i'm kind of gonna
go ahead and shove the dark avengers in
there with them
just in case marvel decides to shove
them into one team
the falcon and the winter soldier
definitely seemed like it was setting up
the thunderbolts i'm actually pretty
shocked that we didn't see thunderbolt
ross at one point that dude
loves super soldier serum but although
we didn't see him we did see
zemo get taken to the raft the raft is a
maximum security prison floating in the
middle of the ocean that thunderbolt
ross is in charge of he essentially has
a roster of villains that he can choose
from in the raft
zemo is currently there right now and
since black widow was supposed to be
before everything and takes place before
the events of avengers in game i'm
guessing that taskmaster might be in
there as well
thunderbolt ross is pretty much going to
be like a kid in a candy shop and he'll
pick his favorite
villains and form together the
thunderbolts team meanwhile john walker
was also recruited by
valentina aka in the comics madame hydra
now it's been established that jon is
us agent and no longer captain america
but maybe he could have been in the
avengers if he actually did a good job
being captain america but he is where he
is now and maybe as u.s
agent he could be a part of the dark
avengers after all we don't really know
what valentina's plan is or who she is
working for but this could be the start
of the dark avengers
then of course we have the mutants and
actually very recently it's been
reported that a mutant's project
is in the works currently at marvel
studios now as far as which mutants
they're going to introduce in the mcu we
don't really know
fox has introduced a fair amount of
mutants in their movies but there are
still plenty that haven't been
introduced yet although we can probably
expect some pretty classic mutants like
cyclops professor xavier magneto
jean grey storm especially if there's
some sort of a connection in black
panther
and i know what everybody is thinking
and hoping for and that is
wolverine but that is actually another
project
only a few weeks ago it was announced
that a wolverine anthology series was in
the works for disney plus
this was reported by the hashtag show
and they state in their report that
although the wolverine anthology series
is still in very early development
marvel is aiming to adapt the famous
weapon x story arc from the comics for
the first
season and they also add that no
wolverine has not been cast yet
if this does end up being true i can see
why marvel has not yet revealed this
everyone is pretty much going to go
crazy when this is announced so i'm sure
they're waiting for the perfect
opportunity
and also probably waiting for a moment
where it doesn't completely overshadow
any other projects they have going on at
the time
another project that could be about to
be revealed is a nova project
kevin feige has actually stated that
they are indeed working on
a nova related project whether this is a
movie or disney plus series or maybe
even putting him in a different movie is
uncertain yet
however guardians of the galaxy did
introduce the nova corps
and the beginning of avengers infinity
war did set up nova pretty nicely
we learned that thanos decimated zandar
and we can pretty much assume that he
killed most of the people on it
if not all of them which means the nova
fours could be making its way to richard
ryder or
sam alexander and then of course last
but certainly not least is a project
that we know is eventually going to come
and that is the new avengers
yes marvel is introducing a lot of new
characters and a lot of
new different projects but that does not
mean that they are done with the
avengers
eventually a new team will be formed
with both existing and
new superheroes in fact we may have just
seen the start of it with
falcon becoming the new captain america
he could go on to be the leader
then he could be joined by captain
marvel spider-man doctor strange and a
whole bunch of new characters that are
about to be introduced to the mcu
now as i mentioned in the beginning
there is kind of a bonus one that i have
here and that is
anyone from any of the marvel netflix
shows
after all it's very heavily rumored that
matt murdock is going to be in
spider-man no way home and could
also be in she-hulk then you have
characters like iron fest who could be
in chongqi
kevin feige has said that we shouldn't
take anything off the table
and that there could be a future for
these characters in the marvel cinematic
universe and
most of these netflix shows were pretty
well received by fans and it would make
sense that if they are going to redo any
of these shows or perhaps sort of revive
them
in the marvel cinematic universe it
would make sense that marvel would want
to keep this very
very quiet so those are some of the
projects that i believe
marvel could be hiding from us right now
but could be announced very soon and if
i hear of any more i'll be sure to tell
you so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss any
of the videos
in the meantime what do you think marvel
could have in the works for us are there
any projects that you may think of that
i didn't list here be sure to put them
in the comments down below and let me
know your thoughts on the video
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you